kuwait it's a small nation located here
between both iraq which many times has
wanted to annex the country and saudi
arabia which has also many times wanted
to annex the country yet despite the
fact that kuwait is much smaller than
its neighbours with very little in the
way of deterrence it still stands which
raises the question why why does kuwait
exist and why hasn't it been annexed by
one of its neighbors so going back to
the mid-19th century kuwait was an
independent shakedom based around kuwait
city with some very loosely defined
fuzzy borders because desert kuwait was
a very busy port which carried goods
from all over the world and as a result
was very rich next door sat both the
ottoman empire and the emirates of nage
which both wanted such a wealthy port
for themselves however the kuwaitis were
able to play both off of each other and
would often submit to paying tribute in
return for its continued independence
that was until the british turned up and
in 1899 the sheikh of kuwait made an
agreement with them in return for
kuwait's continued existence as a
british protectorate and a few sacks of
cash britain would have exclusive
military access to its lands and would
negotiate any border changes on its
behalf the kuwaiti sheikh had hoped that
this treaty with the british would
guarantee his state's independence long
term but fun fact no you see britain
wasn't interested in having to wait for
itself it was interested in france
russia and germany not having it and so
the treaty had effectively allowed
britain to negotiate the status of
kuwait with any power that it wished and
it chose the ottomans the british knew
that the ottoman sultan had wanted
kuwait for a long time and so in 1913
they drafted an agreement with him that
would split the arabian peninsula like
this which as you can see gave kuwait to
the ottomans in return for these lands
for britain as upset as the shake would
have been about this it didn't matter
since the next year world war one and
after the destruction of the ottoman
empire the threat to kuwaiti's existence
was gone for like four seconds because
to the south south the kingdom of nage
which swiftly conquered most of the
arabian peninsula and became the kingdom
of saudi arabia the sauds wanted kuwait
to be a part of their new kingdom and
made several attempts at conquest
between 1920 and 1922 the fighting was
fairly small in scale at first but when
things heated up the british intervened
and put pressure on the south to stop
and in the end it was decided that
kuwait would lose most of its territory
to saudi arabia and in return british
interests there would be protected so to
the north now sat the brand new kingdom
of iraq whose people saw kuwait's
independence as unnatural and only the
result of foreign meddling and as the
decades went on both in iraq and in
kuwait there was an ever growing
movement to unite the two however since
kuwait was a british protector iraq
couldn't invade and the kuwaiti rulers
there imprisoned anyone who wished for
unification which meant that nothing
changed until the 60s and that change
was the decline of the british empire
which left the country in 1961 shortly
after its oil industry had boomed so
being an oil-rich country surrounded by
other larger oil-rich countries meant
that some tensions were inevitable iraq
now led by saddam hussein had racked up
a lot of debt fighting a war with iran
which they believed had been fought on
behalf of the arab world and as such
that world owed them there were some
choice words and kuwait increased its
oil production to punish iraq who then
accused them of stealing oil and so sent
an angry letter and by sent an angry
letter i mean they invaded kuwait in
1919 formerly annexed it into the
country to the rest of the world this
was a bit much and after iraqi forces
refused to withdraw these countries
invaded and drove them out kuwait's
independence was restored and thereafter
there were no further attempts to annex
the country and its existence would be
assured
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bisonette
kelly moneymaker mr wolf sky chappelle
jerry lamdin yn hockey marvin castle
jordan longley gareth turner rod d
martin bugley wiggily captain cydog
spencer lightfoot corso wolfe gustav
swan matthew shipley winston cayward
robert wetzel aaron the white marcus
asner maggie paxkowski anthony beckett
alex schwinn mo the mukwopa coppertone
spinning three plates ben ivinson
charles the first adam stalter and
scottish trekkie